massive storm is pounding the northeast
for a second straight morning torrential
rain high winds and flooding are
reported from new jersey to cape cod
it's a repeat for many areas that were
blasted by hurricane ida just a few
weeks ago this morning the storm is very
slowly moving out to sea mullalangi is
watching its final impact in eastern new
england
waves pounded the massachusetts shore
overnight
the nor'easter's howling near 90 mile an
hour winds whipping the water over
entire houses
crews cleared the roads of fallen trees
south of boston overnight but not before
some trees knocked down power lines
putting tens of thousands of residents
in the dark
the winds uprooted this massive tree on
the cape
slamming it down on top of a car luckily
the passenger inside was not hurt
earlier yesterday heavy rains put this
ridgewood high school's football field
underwater again after it had just gone
through costly repairs due to ida
in upstate new york a flooded creek
swallowed this park trees and all
and in manhattan passengers boarded
subway trains as water trickled in from
above
parts of new york new jersey and
connecticut all saw more rain yesterday
than they typically get in an entire
month
well as the storm tapers off we can
still expect to see rain and wind
throughout the day and of course sites
like this downed trees all over the
place throughout new england causing
hazardous road conditions and power
outages just here in the state of
massachusetts more than 300 thousand
homes and businesses are waking up this
morning to no power jericho
all right mola lange thank you